good afternoon everyone my name is
researcher Miller and the SCP were going
to be looking at today is SCP 2200
object class Keter special containment
procedures the current instance of
scp-2217 tainment chamber at bio site 59
to prevent the relocation of SCP 2200 -
1 a minimum of five armed security
personnel must discord SCP 2200 - -
determination chamber t 28 once a month
to assist in routine d-class cycling in
the event that SCP 2200 - one relocates
mobile task force epsilon 30 played
fielders is to be deployed seek out and
contain the new SCP 2200 - two instance
the area of land encompassing SCP 2200 -
three has been designated site 502 with
foundation faculty members living as
residents in the town proper as SCP 2200
- 3 is populated by anomalous
individuals faculty may acknowledge the
existence of anomalous activity in
general but are not to divulge details
on any SCP object besides SCP 2200 each
staff member living on site is to submit
a weekly report detailing their
experience and interactions for all
intents and purposes SCP 2200 - 3 is to
remain an autonomous community with
minimal political and social
interference by the foundation
additional intervention may be ordered
by the presiding on-site staff lead at
their discretion as a number of inert
instances are already in storage for
testing and archival purposes additional
inert SCP 2200 - 4 are to be collected
and melted down for use in funding
foundation activities
description SCP 2200 is the collective
designation of several interrelated
anomalous phenomena SCP 2200 - one is a
sword 80 centimeters in length composed
of an alloy of silver and copper
estimated to have been constructed
between 500 and 1000 BCE SCP 2200 - one
is luminescent giving off blue light at
a level of brightness directly
proportional to the number of SCP 2200 -
for subjects residing in SCP 2200 - 3
similarly increased numbers of SCP 2200
- for subjects reverses deterioration
caused by SCP 2200 - one's age making it
a more effective weapon SCP 2200 - -
refers to the human individual who is
currently bonded with SCP 2201 SCP 2200
- two subjects cannot separate
themselves from SCP 2200 - one and any
attempt to forcefully remove it from the
subjects grasp will result in the
immediate death of the subject
similarly surgical removal of the hand
or arm bonded to SCP 2200 - one will
also result in death when an SCP 2200 -
- instance dies SCP 2200 - one
anomalously relocates into the hand of
another individual and instantly bonds
with them there is no apparent limit to
the distance SCP 2200 - one can travel
when transporting itself to a new
subject SCP 2200 - one appears to
selectively bond with subjects that
share a similar set of traits see
document 2200 a which suggests that it
may be intelligent to some degree
bonding with SCP 2200 - one will cause
subjects to suffer from an anomalous
form of our gyro --ss which causes their
skin to rapidly develop a distinct blue
hue if an SCP 2200 subject does not end
a human life for an extended period of
time
SCP 2200
will relocate itself after bonding with
a CP 2200 - 1 a CP 2200 - 2 subjects
experience heightened epinephrine and
testosterone levels and immediately gain
an understanding of s CP 2200 in its
entirety these factors combined with the
SCP 2200 - two subjects background C
document 2208 have invariably resulted
in SC p 2200 - - killing those around
them with SC p 2200 - 1 SC p 2200 - 3 is
a 50 kilometer area of land located and
whenever a person is killed by a CP 2200
- 1 a likeness of the individual formed
out of an anomalous silver based alloy
SC p 2200 - 4 will appear in SC p 2200 -
3 despite being made of inorganic
material instances of scp-2217 hundred -
4 instances share the personality and
memories of the victim that they
resemble because of their metallic
composition as CP 2200 - 4 C's aging
after their conversion and are resistant
to physical damage SC p 2200 - 4 do not
need to eat drink or sleep in order to
sustain themselves but may perform these
actions if they so choose instances of
scp-2029 setting foot outside the
designated 50 kilometer squared space SC
p 2200 - 4 instances seem to be innately
aware of the dimensions of safe area any
that leave remain permanently inert and
cannot be restored by being returned to
SCP 2200 3
[Music]
document 2200 a characteristics shared
by a CP 2200 - two subjects between 16
and 34 years of age physically active
strong fear of death negative view of
what happens after death psychological
or emotional instability
the first interview tape we have here is
interview 2200 - I - zero zero one five
interviewed SCP 2200 - two point zero
three seven a 36 year-old male from
British Columbia
interviewer dr. stems forward interview
was conducted on two days after a CP
2200 - two point zero three seven was
detained playing log now alright we're
going to run through this one more time
for the records
please describe the series of events
that transpired after SCP 2200 appeared
in your hand one moment at a time was
just sitting in my bedroom
reading when all of a sudden I had this
vision I saw this place where people
could live for me on an intellectual
level I knew that what I was seeing was
impossible I knew it was true I can't
explain how I just knew and I knew that
I could send people there with the sword
what was your first course of action I
waited until dark I live alone so nobody
knows to be going out in the middle of
the night whenever I came across some
homeless person sleeping alone I'd slit
their throat or stabbed it in the hard
earth something like that it went on
like that for a few nights until a cop
at the cops they turned me over to you
guys well here I am
I see anything else you'd like to add I
want to make it clear that I'm not a
psychopath right I sent those people
away because death could have come for
them and anymore what if they weren't
right with God the way I see it when
someone is sent to that place they're
basically guaranteed eternal life I was
eliminating the risk of hell for them
you know I know it sounds terrible but I
had good
I wasn't really killing though just
sending them to have it kind of or at
least keeping them safe from the
alternative thank you for your time the
second interview we have is interview
2200 I - 0 1 2 4 interviewed SCP 2200 -
2.0 82 a 29 year old female from
Washington USA interviewer researcher
Eva taki forward interview was conducted
three weeks after a CP 2200 - 2 point 0
3 7 was detained playing log now ok if
you're ready please describe the series
of events that transpired after SCP 2200
- 1 appeared in your head I I
immediately knew that my life is pretty
much over
I knew that I couldn't let go of this
sword ever my plans for my life my
career my family all of it was gone but
at the same time I guess I thought I had
an opportunity were you happy with the
situation no God no I would have given
anything to stop what happened so why
did you do it dont you judge me
not for a second what would you do if
you knew you could keep your loved ones
alive forever my sister died when she
was 6
how could I be sure that my kids
wouldn't die young - I hated hurting
them he destroyed me
I knew I was keeping them safe forever
but that didn't make it any easier but
to be honest compared to how I felt when
I saved my family say he strangers felt
like a walk in the park
God surprise the police didn't just
shoot me on the spot that's what usually
happens makes things much more difficult
for us if you see my family please tell
them I'm sorry I'll pass that on thank
you for your cooperation
I know these past few weeks haven't been
easy for you
and the final log we have is interview
2200 - I - 0 207 interviewed a CP 2200 -
four point zero zero five eight one a 68
year old male religious leader in s3
interviewer researcher Pittenger forward
in two days after was detained playing
log now to the next world if you believe
in an afterlife
why have you yourself not crossed the
threshold as well some of us believers
remain to maintain the church continue
to spread the good news
as much as I desire to meet my Heavenly
Father I willingly choose to say bye so
that I might aid those who are still
shackled by fear and doubt opponents of
the exodus movement have accused you of
merely wanted to reduce overpopulation
and increase your own field of influence
how do you answer these allegations I
can understand why the churches existed
so off its critics even among believers
there are those who believe crossing the
threshold to be a sin this equates to
suicide disagreements are a given
religion any additional comments you
would like to be recorded the society is
built upon man's fear of death whether
you believe in heaven or in all
afterlife or finality you must ask
yourself is the pursuit of the
immortality truly virtuous by choosing
to remain safe in our silver shells we
rob ourselves so our dignity by fearing
death we only give it more power and
this concludes our lecture for today
thank you all for listening and you are
all dismissed goodbye
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to Andre Bessette Desmond Hoskins and
Gaza berry thank you all very much for
your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos and some other cool
stuff as well go to patreon.com/scishow
you